bonsoir bruno va passer si merci d'être
avec nous gérald darmanin qui demande
donc aux policiers un 50 ans précisément
c'est pas trop pourquoi 50 opérations de
contrôle et de la saisie systématique
des deux roues dans les quartiers les
plus touchés par par ces rodéos urbains
votre réaction de policiers ce soir au
soir du vous savez pour pour travailler
il faut avoir un certain confort j'ai
envie de dire juridique car vraiment
pour pour stopper ces délinquants c'est
de pouvoir les interpeller en flagrant
délit or le problème c'est que nous
avons des notes bien précises là-dessus
où on nous demande de ne pas dans notre
jargon de policiers chasser les
personnes qui se mettent dans une
position d'un refus d'obtempérer
donc c'est là la grande difficulté de
travailler c'est si on doit travailler
de manière à dire dissuasive ou des
interpellés après l'effraction il va
falloir qu'on soit aussi armé sur un
plan juridique un sachant que des
magistrats bien sûr où un bide de
sanctionner comme nous mais il faut s'en
donner bien sûr les moyens et pas
seulement en renforçant et en plus il
faut en avoir les moyens par 1% les
services de police autour de s'éroder ou
alors pire que cela
cette même note a2 de services de la
commissaire de police de sarcelles
demande à ses effectifs justement de ne
pas entamer de course poursuite
ça veut dire qu'en gros vous êtes un
petit peu impuissant c'est ce que vous
venez nous expliquer c'est bien sûr
incompréhensif dans l'esprit de nos
concitoyens pour nous on a compris qu'il
fallait qu'on travaille mais dès qu'il y
avait on va dire une difficulté la
situation sont rentrés se retourner
contre nous donc comprenez bien que nous
aussi nous allons pas nous mettre en
insécurité juridique je vous prends un
exemple sur un refus d'obtempérer il ya
quelques temps vous avez et ça arrive
régulièrement
vous avez la personne qui a refusé
d'obtempérer elle a été pourchassé par
les policiers cette personne ne sait
c'est s'est blessé mortellement et bien
une enquêtes igpn est en cours autour
des policiers alors nous notre volonté
c'est de ne pas bien sûr d'arriver à un
désastre mais en revanche ce qu'on nous
donne les moyens en effectif pour
pouvoir interpeller en flagrant délit
ces personnes là et là la partie devient
très très compliqué alors les français
en tout cas semble être de votre côté 1
puisque pour 78% d'entre eux on l'a vu
tout à l'heure dans le sujet un sondage
csa pensée news indique que 78 % d'entre
eux sont favorables à cette course
poursuite
quelle est votre lecture de ce sondage
les français sont à bout
ils comprennent qu'il peut être qu'il ne
faut pas qu un sentiment d'impunité
existe oui on comprend ces sondages on
comprend la population de sauver la
population une mutuelle parce qu'elle
sait où se trouvent les dires les
délinquants c'est pas dans les rangs de
la police et lorsque nous en examen
parce que nous avons su une chasse
autour de délinquants de la route
voilà on sait aussi très bien où une
année vous savez je crois que il faut
aller un petit peu plus loin aussi c'est
lorsque nous interpellons le l'auteur ou
lorsque nous retrouvons en tout cas le
la moto et le quad qui a servi à ce
genre de rodéo c'est au delà de la
saisie un bien sûr ne pas le restituer à
son propriétaire en tout cas il doit
être responsable le propriétaire de ce
rodéo parce que c'est pas forcément lui
qui est sur la moto et c'est là où on
devient ça devient compliqué sur le plan
juridique
lorsque vous avez des quads et des motos
qui atteignent 5 6 7 8 10 mille euros
peut-être aussi se poser la question
comment quelqu'un qui touchent le rsa
aps puisse se payer des motos à un tel
prix voyez il faut aller beaucoup plus
loin à partir du moment où on a
travaillé justement autour de autour de
ces rodéos
il faut aller plus loin pour m'attire
vraiment freiné freiner ce genre de
d'activité et se montrer très durs à
l'endroit des propriétaires de ces quads
parce qu'il pourtant coran qui n'étaient
pas sur la moto moins d'effet si on ne
les interpellés après le délit alors en
tout cas depuis le début d'année 597
engins ont été saisis 459 personnes
interpellées dans les zones relevant de
la compétence de la police nationale on
a une idée de ce que sont devenus et les
motos et les gens interpellés ils ont
été punis sanctionné alors je suis pas
j'ai pas vraiment un chiffre précis sur
les sur les sanctions au moins mon sens
elle ne devrait pas être très très très
hot au niveau des individus concernant
concernant les motos ou concernant les
quads
si ces dernières ont de la valeur elles
vont être retenues bien sûr par là par
la justice si elles n'ont pas de valeur
ou si elles sont signalées volées elles
sont restitués dans le cas où elles
n'ont pas de valeur et bien sûr si elles
sont signalées volées ce à partir à la
casse ou en tout cas elles seront
restituées aux propriétaires qui a
signalé le vol de sa moto
donc tout j'ai pas de chiffres vraiment
bien précis mais et c'est très complexe
pour pour travailler alors on salue
quand même bien sûr la volonté d'une
ministre de l'intérieur mais il faut
qu'on soir mais juridiquement j'insiste
bien là dessus parce que vous savez des
sanctions ne sont pas très très lourde
pour ses ces personnes qui font du rodéo
et qui met pourtant de lampard il un
péril la vie de nos concitoyens on a eu
un drame il ya quelques temps où un
enfant de dix ans a perdu la vie à cause
justement de ces inconscients qui font
qu'ils font de la moto d'une manière
manière complètement absurde et ordonnée
merci beaucoup bruno bartocetti d'avoir
été
avec nous en direct sur rt france